people are too afraid to just say what
they actually think about this a lot of
it is our empathy being used against us
but it's been used against us in such a
way that this this lie this Insanity has
taken over our culture
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I'm in Nashville with
author filmmaker and host of the Matt
Walsh show at the daily wire Matt Walsh
Matt thank you so much for taking the
time thanks for having me I appreciate
it and thank you to your team for this
wonderful setup very accommodating yeah
I mean they they gave you a table and
some chairs I don't know how much they
went all out but you know Matt it's been
I guess what June 2022 was when you put
out what is a woman you'll film I should
start with a Hardball question what is a
woman
well I was told finally in adult human
females what a woman is turns out it's
pretty simple
uh well uh I mean there's more there's
more that could be said about women and
about individual women obviously but and
people have uh pointed it out to me
after the film came out that because of
course at the end of the film we spoiler
alert we do have the answer
and that's one uh criticism I've I've
heard from some people it's like well
yeah a woman is that but she's a lot
more than that so isn't that a little
bit reductive to just say a woman is an
adult human female and of course there's
a lot more you can say about an
individual person but we need to have
the the simple biological definition in
place first
so you can build from there so that's
that's the simple definition I see and
so in America now you have to excuse me
because I'm very aware of what's going
on in my country but but here
um in terms of the politics of the
gender Wars let's say or the politics of
the trans issue
what was the state when you put the film
out and how do you think it's changed do
you have you seen an impact of your film
on on the uh the politics of the issue
here yeah I think I think I have uh you
know the film has had uh I
seven
very glad to say that the film has had
uh even a larger impact than we expected
we knew when we were filming it
especially once we started getting
footage we knew that we had something we
had something you know we had something
special but uh it's had an even bigger
impact than I expected it's not just the
film though there's also been there's
been a an organized pushback finally
against this gender ideology Madness uh
of course I'm part of that the film's
part of that but we're not the only ones
um doing it and I think over the last uh
I don't know six to eight months we've
we I it seems to me the pendulum is
swinging a little bit in the other
direction and uh I think that the you
know team sanity has some has uh
has is picking up momentum um what does
that look like what does the pushback
look like well there's it's on a
different levels there's of course
legislative level now we have in
Tennessee they're passing a law
um that bans the uh mutilation of
children the gender transition of
children several other states have
already passed laws a bunch of other
states are are debating laws uh now you
go back a couple years ago it didn't
exist there was no there was no effort
at all to even ban
the mutilation of children uh and now it
is it's become at least you know if
you're a conservative if you're a
republican it's now it's you know it's
it's an issue
and um there's there's Unity around this
around the issue
um so that's the legislative piece and
also I think I think and this is a
little bit harder to quantify but I
think culturally I've noticed in the
last few months people in general seem
more willing to just be honest about how
they feel about all this stuff because
the fact is that most people you know
when a guy that looks like you or I
walks into a room and says I'm a woman
most people think well that's absurd of
course you're not uh
but for years people have been convinced
to suppress that normal reaction and
instead sort of cooperate with it or
entertain it humor it
um and that's how disastrous and a
disastrous impact but it seems to me
that recently that seems to be uh
changing a little bit more more people
are willing to notice that the emperor
has has no clothes
I want I'm curious about whether it's
really most and so for example in
Britain at the polls we just saw with
Nicola sturgeon I was telling you this
before we're recording she she went down
six percent in the post because she
wasn't able to stand up against the the
male who was in the female prison to the
male rapists and uh but in this country
my impression has been
that it's actually split quite down
political lines in fact I'll add to that
in Britain it's split parties that you
have members of labor party it's and
traditional leftists
who
fall on a different side and similar to
how brexit was it wasn't a right left
issue it wasn't it split both parties uh
brexit or leave or remain and I I think
there's a similar thing happening in
Britain on this issue and I wondered
here in America is that the same thing
are there are there conservatives who
has it split the conservative has it
split the liberals or is it sort of more
a liberal versus conservative issue very
broadly speaking it's a little reverse
conservative but the the progress has
been in that you know the people on the
right uh most of them now are willing to
speak out against this whereas for a
long time even people that were on the
right and who saw it for the madness
that it is many of them weren't willing
to say so because they were afraid you
know they were just afraid they were
afraid of uh of being called a bigot or
what have you
um so it's still broadly a right versus
left issue but I I think and again hard
to quantify but
um I think that the majority of people
who identify as liberal
don't really buy
a lot of this you know this to me seems
to be something that's being pushed by a
very loud minority and then by our
institutions our institutions are
totally when I say institutions I mean
Academia media government
Hollywood the Medical Institution
they've fully bought in to gender
ideology completely
um is that changing is that
I I hope so but not but but if there are
any changes they're they're uh
relatively imperceptible right now I
think that there are more doctors that
are coming out but still not very many
you know you see you see some people
within these institutions might small
minorities that are willing to speak out
but uh but for them you know the
consequences are much more dire I mean
if you're a doctor and you come out and
say no we shouldn't be doing this to
kids no a man's a man a woman is a woman
you know you can get plastic surgery but
you're not ever going to actually be a
woman if you're a male um to say that as
a member of the medical profession
Brands you as
a transphobic extremist and that's what
you are now and
I think for a lot of people it's
institutions that that is enough to
terrify them into violence so they've
been in examples of that of any doctors
specifically who have lost or had
professional repercussions sure I mean
we have some of them in our in our film
we talked to uh uh particularly um
psychiatrists and therapists
um you know people that are in
especially in the psychiatric kind of
world of medicine I mean Jordan
Peterson's a big example right you have
who have spoken out against this and
then have been have been uh sort of cast
out of
their
of the polite Society of their
profession because of because of
speaking out against it yeah yeah the
the thing that was very Illuminating for
me is something I did not know before
going to film despite having read quite
a lot on this issue is is the two
characters Alfred Kinsey and John
money what's the story with those guys
if you wouldn't mind reminding sure you
know and the thing is uh I think for a
lot of people they it seems like this
stuff came out of nowhere you know eight
or nine years ago maybe it came out of
nowhere right around the time that Bruce
Jenner came out as Caitlyn and that's
the first time that it became
an issue in the eyes of uh the general
public I think but it but it it existed
before that it pre-existed that
um and so if you want to find the exact
starting point you can kind of decide
how far back you want to go so a little
bit of it it's it's slightly arbitrary
because no matter where you go you say
that's the starting point well there
people influenced those people so but I
think that a landmark moment if you want
to look at Landmark moments you can go
to Alfred Kinsey and John money
um and these were you know uh
psychiatrists and so-called sexologists
in the mid 20th century
um Alfred Kinsey was
you know his his big idea was that human
beings are sexual from birth
um you know even babies are are sexual
creatures and he had these we talked
about the film he had these horrific
unimaginable experiments that he
conducted to try to prove this which
really the experiments involved simply
just raping children
um
and so you have and that was kind of the
beginning of uh of uh what we call
comprehensive sex education and a lot of
stuff we see in the schools now
um things that like in Florida that
they're trying to get out of their
school system well that that traces back
to Alfred Kinsey on the gender issue in
particular
um that's where John money comes into
play and he you know he coined the term
um gender identity uh the the whole
concept actually of human beings having
a gender he was one of the pioneers of
that idea because before
John money
it was you were a man or a woman you had
human beings have a sex uh words have
gender you know talk about masculine and
feminine words but the idea that a
person has both a sex and a gender that
was pioneered by guys like it's not a
feminist thing I thought that was second
wave feminism where the idea that it's
not just about your sex it's how you're
perceived in society yeah yeah I mean
and that's where we can talk about this
later but that's I think that you can
trace there's there's been a close
relationship between gender ideology and
feminism and they've shared a lot of
ideas and in recent years there's been
at least among some feminists the split
um and there are even feminists who
think that you know feminism alone is
the uh is the the weapon that can be
used to take down gender ideology but I
think they don't understand that these
two things are besides the same coin uh
but you know that's in the in around the
mid 20th centuries where this idea first
came into prominence
um that a human being you know it's it's
too simple to just say men and women we
need this other concept of gender
um
which really has had the effect of
complicating things in a way that that
was totally unnecessary and it's always
been kind of this one thing in the film
I I talked to I ask a lot of these
so-called experts but what exactly is
gender and and you know as opposed to
sex and why do we need this concept of
gender and you never get a very clear
answer because it's very sort of
amorphous and it turns out that gender
can just sort of be whatever they needed
to be in the moment rhetorically
um and anyway they've kind of in recent
years
you know they they invented this sex
versus gender distinction in the last
few years they they have collapsed that
distinction effectively they haven't
said they've done it but that's what
they've done because they will tell us
now that well a man who identifies as a
woman isn't just
acting as a woman in the world he isn't
just uh participating in the socially
constructed
idea of Womanhood he they will say he
actually is a woman he is literally a
woman
um which so they have then collapsed
that sex versus gender distinction that
they themselves engineer I think it was
kind of a sleight of hand trick and they
it's it's outlived its usefulness
yeah that's yeah that's a new thing uh
in in again in Britain that it's there's
the feminists or traditional feminists a
lot of them from the left uh famously
like JK Rowling or Suzanne Moore or
Julie Bendel uh who have Kathleen stock
who have had professional repercussions
very much so for their their opinions
have been leading the charts on the
famous thing it's it's doesn't seem like
that's the same story here uh the the
the charge against
uh gender ideology hasn't necessarily
come from feminists am I wrong in
thinking that no you're not it hasn't at
all you know in in America it's been the
pushback against gender ideology is
almost entirely
a conservative thing and not because I I
am a conservative but I don't say that
because I want it to be the case I wish
that it was a broader uh Coalition but
for the most part it is considered like
concern that's a conservative position
now there are some people who would
identify more as liberals who have uh
expressed skepticism about this
something like Bill Maher and guys like
that but they're they're in they're
outliers I think in their in their um I
don't understand how someone like do you
remember Demi minor is the in it's a
transgender who was locked in into
prison in New Jersey and raped two other
female actual female uh prison uh
inmates yeah how an incident like that
doesn't
shock American feminists it's such a
it's such a it's so everything they've
been fighting for for the security of
women surely some someone like Demi
minor would set off the alarm Bells has
that it's is that not happened
uh I think it had it has only in uh in
small doses uh I think generally
speaking uh I mean in fact I I have
tested this because I went to the
women's March feminist March in DC and
asked about asked about this I asked
about this issue of gender ideology and
what I encountered was uh nearly a
hundred percent on board for the trans
what they call Trans rights
um
it should shock them and it should wake
them up
why it hasn't is a good question I think
it has
I think there's a lot some of it is
tribalism I think they just associate
now it's it's to be to be um anti-gender
ideology because they associate with
conservatism they say well I don't want
to be I don't want to be with the likes
of you know I don't want to be like that
guy
um so some of it is just a tribalistic
thing and some of it is is this
intersectionality it's just kind of uh
the sort of victim hierarchy on the left
that they feel beholden to and on the
left the left-wing ideology is that you
know
there are there's this hierarchy of
victimhood and sort of the Uber victims
are uh trans people and so anytime
there's a conflict between groups or
conflicting rights claims like the
trans person says I have a right to
access the women's room and the woman
says well I have a right to privacy on
the left because of their
intersectionality victimhood math the
trans person that he wins out because
he's uh more oppressed and he's a the
the greater victim
so how so it's if it's just
conservatives uh uh coalescing against
this yeah not not just but well mainly
mainly yeah how do you see things moving
forward where does where does progress
what does progress look like for you in
the movement
well I think it's it
it again isn't is in various different
facets
um it continues on the legislative area
uh you know there should be this is a
it's a good place to start no I'm not
I'm not satisfied to just say well the
red States will ban the mutilation of
minors and we'll leave it at that I'm
not saying that at all because there are
still kids in all these other states
we're not going to abandon them but I
think we do have to start there
um and there are a lot of uh states
where we should have political Sway and
we're finally starting to see movement
there so I think that's that's a lot of
the progress
and then on a culture wide level I think
it's about
just emboldening people sort of get
letting them know they have permission
to be sane and to uh
speak the truth because we talk about
the left first right distinction but the
reality is most average people
um
probably don't think of themselves as
terribly ideological and aren't very
ideological and
um
you know if you're a died in the wool
leftist and you're all into the
intersectionality it's gonna be very
hard to reach those people but I think
there are a lot of people in the middle
sort of
who can be uh who can be reached do you
other people are you in dialogue with
any sort of progresses of people who
have different opinions are you able to
have constructive conversations are
there any individuals who are having
constructive conversations with on this
issue
um no I wish you know I I even um
here in Tennessee I mentioned the law
that we're that we're uh that's going to
be passed
Banning this and I have reached out to
some you know the Democrats in the state
are against the law they don't want to
pass I reached out to some of the
Democrats and invited them let's let's
have a debate about it you know let's
sit down like we're right now and you
explain to me why it's okay to do this
to a child
um but they're just they're not
interested in in having a conversation I
think that they
I can't breathe their minds but I think
at some level they know that their
position is indefensible
um and they're not going to put
themselves in a position where they're
facing someone who's actually skeptical
of their world because they can't they
can't defend it it's just it's
impossible to defend how are you going
to sit across from somebody and look
them in the eye and tell them yeah you
know what sometimes it's the right thing
to amputate a 14 year old girl's healthy
breasts like
I think they recognize that they can't
they can make that argument to to a
crowd that already agrees with them but
to talk to someone who doesn't it's just
it all falls is it is it the children
aspect that is
so is so emotional for you because so I
see it that there's there's the the
aspects of the mutilation of children
and uh the hormone blockers Etc then
there's also the mutilation of the truth
you could say or the the Distortion of
of Truth the concept of truth that's
played with and another thing which
which probably was for me the uh why I
started to care the most about the issue
is is about protecting women I I my I
have a duty to protect my mum and my
sister and the idea that biological men
are in toilets with with them is
unacceptable to me so that was the thing
that was sort of my hook in to the to
the topic on a personal level what was
yours
uh really it's well you said the
mutilation of the truth which I like
that I might steal that line I don't
know I hadn't thought of that yet uh but
to me that's that's the starting point
and that is the most important thing
um
and all the other stuff grows from that
route once we uh abandon truth as a
society
then you know then then all bets are off
and the whole reason why
you know
the reason why it's terrible to do this
to a child the primary reason like why
is it why is it a terrible thing to try
to turn a 15 year old girl into a boy
well because it's not possible because
she can't she can't be a boy she's not
so that's what makes it mutilation
that's what makes it it's not medical
treatment it's mutilation and the reason
why is because it's not true
um so I think that's that's the starting
point for me it's just like this is not
true it's not true and that's and that's
why it matters
um the thing that makes it really
personal for me is is the way that kids
are affected by it I have six kids and
um
you know they are we homeschool them and
we do my oldest kids are nine so it's
still relatively easy to Shield them
from a lot of this craziness
but eventually they're gonna end up in
the world and they're going to be
subjected to this and I hear from
parents all the time just these horror
stories of you know I raised my kid I
did everything right I even homeschooled
I did whatever and then uh one day my
daughter at 16 comes home and declares
that she's a boy and from that moment
it's just she is
devoured by this cult almost overnight
and becomes unrecognizable she wants
nothing to do with us anymore I've heard
the story so many times um and it's
terrifying it's
horrific you know it's uh
I think as a parent it's like a fate
worse than death in a lot of ways you're
losing your child
it's like a death of a child while
they're still alive and um
so that's what makes it I suppose
personal for me yeah I I suppose one
thing that I've
uh maybe we'll find disagreement on
um is uh Dylan Mulvaney and
um so Dylan Mulvaney is the uh trans
Tick Tock personality I think he's 26
years old I think he's now made a lot of
money uh through sponsorships and there
was even an interview with him in Biden
uh last year at the moment not mistaken
and um
so you went viral not long ago uh with a
video
um
uh well I would say attacking him but
you might disagree with that
um
and I want to challenge you on this
because
um
have you say things like that he is a
lifeless unearthly and eerie and uh a
kind of human deep fake
and
um and you've also sort of doubled down
and said that if uh if you if you're the
sort of person who thinks this is mean
then you yourself are part of the
problem
in that case I'm part of the problem
because I do think that this is
unnecessarily ad hominem or the attack
on him was unnecessarily ad hominem and
uh so I I
um I wanted to sort of understand why
I'm part of the problem for thinking
that you might have gone too far with
with Dylan
well
the first question I have to ask is do
you think do you think I'm wrong what I
said is wrong
yes what's part of it because when I see
Dylan Mulvaney I see a temple of God I
see that he is loved by Christ and that
he is possibly unwell and certainly
being misguided by people around him
um and and so I feel it it makes me sad
when I see uh that that character assume
I don't think he's unearthly on the on
the contrary I I see him as as precious
just uh uh it's in his I mean this might
sort of be uh I guess people might think
it's condescending of me to think but
but I sort of feel a bit sad for him so
uh so I do disagree I think with your
take well you're using the word him do
you think that he is a child of God
has human dignity which I agree with
what I'm referring to is this charade
this uh play that he's putting on
where he in the video in particular that
I was reacting to that started all this
was keep in mind this is someone who is
is putting on a caricature of Womanhood
uh that is degrading and demeaning and
women have told him how demeaning it is
and he keeps on doing it and he
monetizes it and profits off of it and
he uses it for clicks and for uh get
Tick Tock followers and all that and he
doubles down and then uh and then
finally he does a video talking about
how what an attractive woman he is and
he's going to steal your husband and
he's talking and he's very clearly
talking to the women he's sort of
taunting the women who have told him how
demeaning all this is to be caricatured
the way that he is
um
that whole display
is all the things that I described it as
and what makes it that what makes it
unearthly and eerie and all the words
that I use there
is that is that he is a he he's a he's a
man
okay so it's it's this this effort to
flee from that and to put on this this
charade in this play that is and you
could use you know you might use a
synonym that makes means the same thing
it's disturbing it's ridiculous right I
mean it's all those things well I think
I think the difference is
that you could say the display or that
particular video was maybe I mean maybe
you found it threatening I saw I didn't
find it threatening I just thought it
was sad but if you let's say you think
that the video or the display is
self-threatening then you can criticize
the video and the display but it seemed
to me that it was actually his very
existence that you were uh challenging
and and uh do you think that designer's
existence is what he's doing
it's what he's choosing to do that I'm
challenging and that I'm describing in
language that I think
is
simply simply captures what he's doing
it's it is a simple description
um ad hominem would be would be a
description that's out of bounds that
doesn't that doesn't apply that's that's
said just for the the sake of of being
insulting
um I'm saying it because it is just true
and what I think and the reason why I
say that uh this reaction of Well it's
mean
is part of the problem is that this is
in fact how we have gotten to this place
in our culture because
um because people are too afraid to just
say what they actually think about this
and because we've been so afraid that a
lot of it is our is our you know our
politeness our empathy being used
against us
but it's been used against us in such a
way that this this lie this Insanity has
uh taken over our culture you know this
this emotional manipulation of well you
can't say that because it might we'll
hurt their feelings and what they might
hurt themselves you know it's it's uh
that's what it's it's an emotional
blackmail and we can't hope to get to a
point where truth prevails in our
culture until we're willing to say I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be blackmailed
okay for the same reason we won't
negotiate with terrorists this is like
an emotional terrorism that they're uh
engaging in and so we have to say as
rough as it might sound
we're not going to play that game you're
not going to manipulate us here's the
truth about what you're doing
and that's it and lay the cards on the
table the other thing I'd also say about
Dylan Mulvaney is that um
you said that he's being manipulated
right I think that's what you said yes
I said I said I imagine he's being
misguided by people misguided
um maybe maybe not I don't know but but
what I do know is that he is misguiding
other people okay so what whatever what
got him to this state I'm not sure
exactly but he is manipulating and
misguiding he is now a proponent of this
this thing
um so he's not just Dylan Mulvaney he
now wants to turn he wants to recruit
other people to be Dylan Mulvaney okay
he wants to do that with my kids
and anyone else's kids
um that's why he's at the white house uh
Shilling for gender affirming care for
minors which is in other words
mutilating and castrating children so
once you do that you're engaging in
politics you're a public figure you are
now a representative of this idea
um that also gives me even more I
believe moral license to be brutally
honest with you especially as a father
and um
when I perceive you as a threat to my
children which the proponents of this
movement are
than uh
I'm not going to apologize for any
language that I use
in opposing that do you think that
it's possible to have a non-binary
approach where it's not
so drastic all the way so another way of
thinking a bit be
those people who are unsure about the
issuers you know it's quite an
intimidating issue if you're coming into
it like well I remember when I first
came into it it's puzzling the language
is new and weird and and if they if
their first entry point is to see you
going after no I agree he's in the
public domain so his ideas are up for uh
scrutiny and and in fact that's you go
into the public domain of ideas it's
totally ideas says appearances too
because he is making videos and again
profiting off of them monetizing them
where you say what an attractive woman I
am look at me I'm going to steal your
husband okay you you have now you have
now entered you have not just your ideas
you have entered your self and your
appearance okay and so I'm allowed to
respond to that it just even if it was a
public figure if someone comes up to me
and says aren't I so attractive I'm
going to answer you honestly don't ask
the question if you don't want an answer
but especially if you're doing it on a
public stage
um then you have now uh
you know you have sort of entered that
into evidence now you've you've you've
brought that up in the court of public
opinion you've entered that conversation
and so now we're going to have it but I
I know I just got you I didn't mean to
cut you off well go ahead sorry well I I
just
I I I still would land uh I'm not fully
convinced in in your direction because I
think that in in in the public
discipline discourse and particularly as
you are clearly a man on a mission feels
very passionately and and I happen to
agree with you on a lot of I love this
on this topic about that we are as a
society your society and my Society have
are really going off course and it's
hurting children
and so if the objective is to bring
people on side
and the objective is to change the
course of society how best do we achieve
that do you think that that video that
of you and and you're doubling down is
going to achieve that that ends do you
think it will work
uh not all by itself but it's part of a
strategy that works yeah now what you uh
would you say at the beginning that this
is not a it's doesn't have to be a
binary approach I I agree with you on
that okay so it's not it's not like it's
should we be aggressive in our language
as I was or not
um
there's a place for a lot of different
approaches
and even
what I said there in the way that I
approached it that's not how I'm going
to go about it in every possible
scenario
that is public stage I'm a public figure
talking to a camera
to someone else who's also a public
figure who is speaking to a camera
um and
we are both advocates for our
world view and for our idea we are we we
are combatants in a culture War the two
of us still a mulvanian myself
um
and so that's going to call for a
certain approach if I'm just speaking
personally to someone who's struggling
with gender dysphoria
um would you be brutally honest would
you say yeah I'd be very honestly or
eerie and and unearthly
I in a in a personal exchange especially
if there's no cameras around just a
personal exchange is someone who's not a
public figure but not really an advocate
for this they're just like seeking
counsel then I'm going to be honest with
them but obviously I'm going to be less
aggressive in the way that I approach it
um and there are examples of that by the
way I mean I was I can't remember which
college I was I was but uh
a few months ago I was speaking out of
college and in the Q a a guy got up
there a kid and a gender dysphoria and
um
he was obviously like hurting and he was
in pain and I spoke with him
honestly I didn't lie to him
but it was a much softer approach
because the situation called for it
not every situation calls for it and in
a culture War you cannot approach every
situation as if you are having a
one-on-one emotional conversation with a
person who's seeking your counsel not
every situation is like that
um and I think that
the on on a
on a culture-wide level the more
aggressive approach
is not only morally Justified I'm 100
sure of that I'm also 100 sure that it's
a good strategy because
um number one it it mobilizes your own
side you know people say
Don't Preach to the choir you know you
don't want to preach the choir well
well no you should preach to the choir
the choir is in the church like they're
they're the first ones who need to be on
your side if you don't even have the
choir on your side then you're in
trouble
um and the people in the pews you need
to preach to them what you don't want to
do is is uh calibrate your message water
it down to try to appeal to people that
are walking outside on the sidewalk and
in in the in the process you're
demoralizing the people who are in the
church
and actually in fact that's what actual
churches have been doing for years and
it's why they're dying and uh is what
conservatism has also been doing
um I think you need to
you need to mobilize the troops as it
were and part of that is using
aggressive language and the other thing
I would also say one one last point
is the idea that being more that being
nicer and uh more gentle
that that's how you win
that is
utterly refuted
by the fact that we that we right now
live in a culture that's dominated by
the left and that's not how they did it
they didn't do it through kindness and
winning uh flies with honey and all that
they did it by being aggressive and bold
and
by painting their oppositions are by
using a tone that communicates that
their opposition's argument is not just
wrong but morally deranged and insane
that's how they'll that's how the left
will treat you if you say something they
disagree with you're not just wrong you
are a monster and you're saying
something that doesn't even deserve to
be taken into consideration
say what you want about it that strategy
is very effective it's been proven
effective the difference is that they do
that to us
dishonestly like they're painting that
we can say something that's true and
they react to it as if it's the most
insane thing they've ever heard
meanwhile they're saying things that are
actually insane and we uh you know we
soft pedal our response to lend it
legitimacy I'm saying we should throw
the exact same strategy back at them
because it not only does it work but in
their case it's actually warranted what
they're saying is insane nightmarish
Madness and we should does it work
though because so what you're saying is
the left have been doing this to
conservatives for a long time so we're
going to do exactly the same thing
because we're actually we think we're
right on this issue but is it going to
actually make things better or is it
just going to
lead to more uh is isn't it just uh
synthesis and uh thesis and antithesis
instead of the synthesis synthesis
you're just you're just you're adding
fuel to the fire that's gonna
escalate the situation rather than
de-escalate and and is is there a is
there sort of a putting your arm out
across the aisle type moment that's
possible or is it do we need to no well
is that is that that's why I'm talking
about this binary I don't I'm not
totally convinced that the the the the
the the way to oppose it that's why I
think you were very effective in your
film what as a woman because it's
actually it's a fun film it's not uh
you're not you don't totally you let you
let the everyone speak for themselves
and so the audience makes up their mind
so it's actually very effective and and
actually almost I would say that is the
non-binary that's the middle I know you
created the film and you edited it so in
a sense you had a control but actually
it was it was that I'm sure would have
had a lot
bigger impact in trying to bring people
who are unsure who didn't understand the
issue who are on to understanding it
from from how you see it so I I can see
that as effective whereas this I worry
it would actually push people away
well that's why I said no it's you're
not going to have one strategy for every
given situation and uh for a film you
know we decided early on that the most
effective thing for a film
um in particular we are also making a
piece of entertainment we want it to
have an impact but part of having an
impact is for it to be effective as a
piece of entertainment which is
something that I think conservatives
often um
that that's where they tend to fail when
they try to make you know uh missional
sort of uh pieces of content where they
put the mission way ahead of the actual
entertainment value
um and then you just end up with a with
a sermon
um so we didn't want to do that and so
that's what we decided to do with with
what is woman
but also make no mistake that this was
not no one is pretending that this was
actually an objective
um exploration of the issue as if I was
a neutral Observer I didn't have a point
of view I did like I had an intention in
mind I want I wanted to do something I
this was a this was a also a a salvo in
the culture War
um and it was intended to be and we had
a certain strategy and we executed it
um
but different strategies call for
different things when I'm when I'm
speaking when I'm doing a podcast and
I'm it's I'm giving my point of view and
I'm again addressing someone who is
someone on the other side and is a
powerful in their own way advocate
for that position then um
I'm not going to take the pose of
someone
who's mutually asking questions I'm I am
aggressively meeting it head-on to your
question about uh is there is there a
moment of extending a hand
[Music]
um
I think no there's not there there is no
compromise on this issue because either
men or men and women are women or not
either biological sex exists or it
doesn't
um either it's possible for
a man to become a woman or not like
these are these are this is this is
about that that is a binary Choice it's
either it's either yes or no and any
compromise in the middle like it when
truth compromises with falsehood
any any compromise is a victory for
falsehood because any any step you take
away from the truth you are you are now
in the realm of falsehood might be
degrees you know it's like some some
ideas are crazier than others
but it's still false the worry for me to
hear that is that that I you know I've
just come from New York surrounded by
progressives they believe that they are
speaking the truth so if everyone thinks
that speaking the truth and and you know
I don't think putting your hand out
means that you're agreeing to the to
necessarily to what the other person
says but you're agreeing to enter into
uh good faith discussion and what I
worry about being in and out of your
great country is that the concept of
truth there's just two truths there's
two realities in this country and I
don't quite see how they're reconciled
do you see how they're reconciled they
don't I agree with you they can't be
reconciled but that that's because
there's only one truth and a lot of
people that are saying that well this is
my truth they're just wrong and and
that's it and uh the only
um
Harmony
that's possible is for them to come over
to the side of Truth or for people on
the side of Truth to go over to
falsehood like that there's no you know
there the the two sides and then you
have this vast uh Canyon in the middle
and um so there's no meeting in the
middle you try to be in the middle
everybody just Falls in uh but but there
is there is a potential for Unity but it
involves one side just giving it up and
going to the other
um
and
I'm not possible well it's yeah yeah I
mean it's it's possible I think it will
happen
not anytime soon this is a generational
struggle
but I'm I I have my flag planted on what
I know is the truth and I'm not leaving
it I'm not I'm not going to walk in an
inch away from it and so if you want to
be United with me you need to come to me
that's my I will extend my hand to bring
you over here I'm not going to meet you
in the middle I'm not going over there
I'm not even going to walk an inch
towards you
um and uh I do think that generationally
on a generational level
we can achieve victory that way
um
or or not I mean it's not guaranteed and
so maybe eventually those of us who are
standing next to that flag we're going
to be standing there completely alone
and isolated uh as the losers in the
great cultural struggle
and if that happens I don't I don't
think it will ultimately but if it does
it does
uh but we haven't
given up the truth you know there's just
there's no Victory there's no Victory no
real Victory is possible if you
abandon the truth
um well I want to ask you also about the
state of conservative media and Free
Speech actually in your country of
course the country where free speeches
uh enshrined in the Bill of Rights and
First Amendment and yet we saw the
Twitter files the conservative voices
are muted or Trends blacklisted or
Shadow banned and also there was a story
last week about global disinformation
index which has found it's partly funded
by the U.S state Department where they
list
problematic or I think that the term
they use is riskiest
media companies and the daily wire being
one of the most that included the New
York Post who published and had the
hunter Biden story censored
um and being at the daily wire I
wondered
how it feels from the inside do you feel
like your voice is being censored and
what does that mean practically speaking
for your for your work
um I I certainly feel the attempts we
feel the attempts to suppress and uh and
it yeah it comes under the guise of uh
often comes with the under the guise of
you know fact-checking uh
combating misinformation but we know
that when they talk about misinformation
they just mean information that they
don't
you know when the powers that be say
misinformation I mean information that
is inconvenient to our narrative is what
they mean by misinformation
um it's such a bizarre term because it's
just you just mean propagate like what
is it it's just a new word for fake news
or for propaganda but it's used by yeah
allegedly I mean something that's not
true and you know misin information
these are the truth or there's a lot
right it's a lie
um but then you know the problem when
you have a uh people that have taken
upon themselves to
differentiate misinformation from
information it's well how do you trust
their judgment why should we trust them
and most of the people that have
declared themselves the you know
official fact Checkers I don't trust
them at all because they're obviously
partisan so we feel that that effort
um
but fortunately it's it's uh I think it
was becoming harder and harder for
them to actually suppress
speech you know and um especially as
we're building the daily wire we have
you know over a million subscribers now
and um I think conservatives and media
in particular are starting to realize
this you need to build your own
platforms it's always precarious when
you're relying on these platforms that
are owned by
people that hate us and at any moment I
could just hit a button and we're erased
from existence effectively
so ultimately the answer is to
break ourselves of that dependence but
that that is also a slow process the the
the the thing that I know in Britain I
think it's I think they're called love
not hate but they've been uh running
smear campaigns against TV news but what
they do is they it's they stop companies
from uh having their advertising on the
channels and that's where the real hair
is because it means you can't generate
the same sort of money
so that to to run the or run the new
institution as you're doing and I think
that's actually specifically for this
new Global disinformation index which is
the issue is that they're advising
advertising companies not to put their
uh you know adverts on on such and such
channels we've seen this with Fox News
Fox News for
forever I guess which is why they've got
the sort of adverts about pillows and
coins and and nothing else is is that
does that do you feel that Brunt
um yeah we feel uh it's it's definitely
clear that there are some you know Major
Brands a lot of them that just they
won't go anywhere near
anything that smells of conservatism and
largely because of efforts by these you
know organizations
um putting the pressure on them
but that also goes back to it's another
reason for building your own platform
where you're not you know well you don't
have most conservatives in media and uh
just even not in media it's like you're
you're dependent on platforms run by
people who hate you and also advertisers
who hate you and it just becomes it's a
it's an untenable situation in the in
the long run you're completely
vulnerable
um
having said that on on the other side is
you've got millions of subscribers on
YouTube Spotify and uh all the social
media platforms so actually it's maybe
not as bad as
some people may think it is yeah you can
right now as it stands right now you can
uh
you can navigate it's it's navigable
um and
but it still feels like I don't have any
illusion that I don't know it's hard for
me to put timeline on it but
but 10 years from now
it's hard for me to imagine that there
are still going to be people doing like
what we do on YouTube Because at a
certain point they're just gonna cut it
off and say we can't you're being
your audience has grown grown too much
and you're being effective and we just
we can't allow it anymore so we're going
to cut you off
um which just puts a little more urgency
in you know getting your own platforms
built but in the meantime
you know what one of the platforms where
it was becoming almost impossible to
navigate the kind of censorship uh
regime was was Twitter
um where it got to a point where you
know you weren't even allowed to say if
you if you said
that
a male is a man you're banned
permanently that kind of thing but then
Elon Musk took over and a lot of that
has been tamped down
um that's literally True by the way
there's an exact famous example in
Britain was the Irish comedian Graeme
linen who's actually been the guest in
this show uh uh he got banned suspended
from Twitter for tweeting men aren't
women though and and there's plenty of
other examples of it and it's yeah it's
interesting that Twitter went that
direction and now we know what happened
with the Elon Musk
um the other platforms aside from I'm
not an expert in all these platforms
rules but uh and I tend to just do I I
just make my content I put it out there
and they're going to do what they're
going to do with it the platforms I mean
but
the other platforms aside from Tick Tock
haven't gone that far
um to just flat out say like on YouTube
I know that for a fact because if
YouTube made a rule saying you're not
allowed to quote unquote misgender
um a trans person then I'd be I would
have been banned 50 times over
um they haven't
they haven't flipped that switch yet I
don't know when they will or if they
ever will I suspect eventually they will
um so uh finishing on a positive note
Matt Walsh what are you excited about
what's next when's the next film what
what projects are you working on what
what have you got your eyes on
uh it's a whole lot of things that I
can't say anything right but uh but I
will say that you know last year was I
mean it was just an incredible year uh
for me personally and for the company
and because of the film because of the
film and and we were just you know I I I
do you know how what the views are now I
don't know the exact number of people I
can say that in the first just to give
it a I think the best frame of reference
is that um when the film came out we had
600 000 subscribers to daily wire within
a month of it being out we were up at
about 900 000. you know so we grew by 50
in a month because of the film yeah
um and uh certainly Millions have
watched it and then and then you know
really the the major impact of the film
I think has been all these clips that
are out there been viewed tens of
millions of times if not more
um so it was that was it was great but
but also just like just getting out and
you know holding rallies and showing up
at school boards and just actually being
out sort of on the street mobilizing uh
so you're doing a lot of on the grounds
yeah and I I did a lot of that last year
and we've already done some this year
and I want to I want to continue doing
that because that's the one thing that
becomes uh
frustrating in the the media business is
that you spend all day just talking
about these things and you go home and
you get up and you talk about it more at
least for me it becomes it's like
personally demoralizing it that's all
you do I just I need to be out there
actually actively doing something and uh
so what does that look like being out
there actually you you're well at the
state capital yeah we've uh just a few
examples we held uh we held a big rally
here in Nashville a couple months ago
Against Child mutilation we had
thousands of people show up I believe
it's the biggest rally in in the nation
on this particular topic that's been
held against what specifically against
uh the transitioning of miners in the
state and then shortly after that they
introduced the bill to ban it so we had
a real impact there it felt felt good
about that you know I've gone to school
board meetings to speak out against
um
various forms of indoctrination that go
on in in the school boards
um and of course yeah and of course and
also making the film was uh you know
something that's beyond just you know
you do a podcast and you you say a lot
of things and then people watch it and
hopefully it makes some kind of impact
but then they forget about it five
seconds later and you're just you're
churning out a lot of content that's
forgotten very quickly um
but to be able to make a piece of
content that people will actually
remember months down the line a couple
of years down the line
um is a lot more uh a lot more
fulfilling I suppose hope to do more of
that but you can't tell me exactly what
no I cannot say a single word okay well
uh I better pay close attention yeah
Matt stay tuned thank you so much for
taking the time absolutely thank you
[Music]